herr präsident meine damen und herren
bundeskanzler willy brandt gab seine
regierung ein leitmotiv
er sagte wir wollen mehr demokratie
wagen
wir freien demokraten knüpfen heute an
diesen gedanken wieder an mit unserem
gesetzentwurf wollen auch wir sagen wir
wollen mehr demokratie wagen mehr
parlamentarische demokratie in der
pandemie meine damen und herren dass das
parlament in der pandemie gestärkt
werden muss hat die letzte plenarwoche
bewiesen
der gesundheitsminister hielt hier eine
regierungserklärung und während er
sprach plante das kanzleramt bereits
tief greifende grundrechts beschränkung
auf infektions rechtlicher grundlage
diese dinge wollte die kanzlerin dann in
einer besprechung mit dem
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidentin also einer mpk
durchsetzen
dazu verlor der minister hier im plenum
kein wort die kanzlerin auch nicht
stattdessen ließ sie am donnerstag in
einem parteigremium die katze aus dem
sack das wurde an medien durchgestochen
ab donnerstag abend gab es dann
berichterstattung dazu
der freitag war als sitzungstag abgesagt
und später legte die kanzlerin ihre
beweggründe nicht hier im parlament
sondern in der bundespressekonferenz
der journalist robin alexander
kommentierte die vorgänge in der
tageszeitung der welt vom 22 januar
dieses jahres wie folgt und ich zitiere
blamiert ist der bundestag und weiter
das grenzt an selbstaufgabe zitat ende
meine damen und herren das parlament ist
die herzkammer unserer demokratie
behandelt wo sie in den letzten wochen
aber wie ein wurmfortsatz es sollte die
gemeinsame überzeugung aller
parlamentarierin hier sein dass nicht
länger hinzunehmen und dem dient unser
gesetzentwurf
die bundesregierung verschärft mit ihrem
neuerlichen vorgehen ein altes problem
die gewaltenteilung wird schon seit
jahren durch ein phänomen untergraben
dass der cdu kollege thomas de maizière
in seinem sehr lesenswerten buch
regieren innenansichten der politik wie
folgt beschreibt und ich zitieren
zentrale wichtige entscheidung verlagern
sich zu sehr weg von bundesregierung und
der koalitionsausschuss bundestag oder
bundesrat hin zu den besprechungen der
bundeskanzlerin mit den regierungschefs
der länder und ich zitiere weiter seine
empfehlung die besprechung der
bundeskanzlerin mit dem
ministerpräsidenten darf nicht zur haupt
instanz der politischen willensbildung
in deutschland werden meine damen und
herren der kollege de maizière hat recht
aber das genaue gegenteil betreibt diese
bundesregierung sie macht aus der mpk
die haupt instanz der politischen
willensbildung in der panne wie das geht
jetzt schon ein jahr lang so wie lange
wollen wir das eigentlich hier noch
hinnehmen meine damen und herren
bei der stellung des parlaments geht es
nicht nur um demokratische legitimation
und um gewaltenteilung
es geht auch um die qualität der
beschlüsse die dabei am ende rauskommen
gmbh ist auf dauer kein gutes
entscheidungs format ministerpräsidenten
und ministerpräsidentin sind in der
korona krise dauer gestresst sie sind
durchweg generalisten keine spezialisten
das phänomen des gruppendenken setzt
eines führt selbst bei kompetenten
personen zu schlechteren und
realitätsfernen entscheidungen das hat
die wissenschaft immer wieder gezeigt
und zudem lassen mehr und mehr
aufmerksamkeit und konzentration dort
nach der ministerpräsident bodo ramelow
hat das erst vor wenigen tagen in seinem
handy quatsch geständnis zugegeben meine
damen und herren
und so wundert es auch nicht dass viele
ministerpräsidenten in der mpk erst
immer wieder beschlüssen zustimmen
von denen sie sich dann wenige stunden
später auch schon wieder in thal
lossagen meine damen und herren es doch
verrückt und so wundert es auch nicht
dass nach solchen sitzungen november
hilfen verkündet werden
die gegen das beihilfenrecht der eu
verstoßen dann erst wieder nachgebessert
werden müssen mit der folge dass viele
betroffene heute immer noch auf diese
hilfen warten meine damen und herren die
bürgerinnen und bürger haben besseres
als das verdient und dem dient unser
gesetzentwurf die lösung für mehr
parlamentarische demokratie in der
pandemie sieht wie folgt aus möchte die
bundesregierung in der mpk eine
bundesweit einheitliche pandemie politik
durchsetzen dann braucht sie auch eine
zustimmung des deutschen bundestages
dafür denn bundesweite angelegenheit
bundesweite angelegenheiten bedürfen
einer bundespolitischen legitimation
wenn nämlich die bundesregierung mit
bundesweiter wirkung jenseits der
technischen kompetenzen des bundes tätig
wird dann muss sie der bundestag dabei
auch politisch effektiv kontrollieren
und steuern können und genau das
ermöglicht unser gesetzentwurf der
bundestag ist auch schnell
handlungsfähig das hat er immer wieder
bewiesen die bundeskanzlerin kann auch
jederzeit eine sondersitzung verlangt
schon von verfassungs wegen und deshalb
frage ich mich was man überhaupt dagegen
haben können sollte als parlament seine
steuerungs und kontrollfunktion in
dieser weise effektiv auszug meine damen
und herren das sollte unser gemeinsames
interesse sein dass man das parlament in
der pandemie stärken kann zeigt heute
morgen übrigens das land nordrhein
westfalen die koalition aus union und
fdp unter der führung von armin laschet
und joachim stamp bringt in diesen
stunden ein gesetz zur parlamentarischen
absicherung der rechtsetzung in der coop
19 pandemie ein
die süddeutsche zeitung schreibt über
diese initiative dass sie unter einem
motto von willy brandt stehen könnte
mehr demokratie wagen mehr demokratie
wagen wir wollen heute auch im bund mehr
demokratie wagen mehr parlamentarische
demokratie in der pandemie wagen und
genau dem dient unser gesetzentwurf mit
leichten partners jetzt marco buschmann
am schluss noch mal
der bundestag solle beteiligte werden
er bringt nordrhein westfalen als zum
beispiel ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
ob das vergleichbar ist denn über den
verordnungsweg ist es ja so dass die
ministerpräsidenten in ihren
bundesländern entscheiden und in der tat
dort die parlamente mitentscheiden
könnten der bundestag sagte fdp soll
aber entscheiden wenn es überall
bundeseinheitliche maßnahmen gibt die
zur herbeizuführen sind rudolf henke
jetzt für die cdu/csu es mitglied im
ausschuss für gesundheit und der
ehemalige vorsitzende des marburger
bundes meine damen und herren zunächst
begrüße ich mal den wunsch nach einem
bundeseinheitlichen abgestimmten
vorgehen und ich begrüße auch dass damit
die gestern ja auch wiederholt
vorgetragenen plädoyers dafür wieder
aufgegriffen werden ich will erinnern an
die gestern auch schon erwähnte
initiative des landes schleswig holstein
unter beteiligung unter beteiligung der
fdp der grünen und der union einen
perspektiv plan vorzulegen für einen
vorschlag schleswig holsteins ab 15
februar bis april also der
bundesregierung vorzuwerfen dass sie
pläne schmiedet die sie mit den
ministerpräsidenten diskutieren will
und im fall von schleswig holstein zu
sagen so ist es richtig das ist ein
widerspruch den sie erstmal auflösen
müssten erst der zweite bemerkung fast
alle forderungen die sie hier vortragen
sind bereits heute im
infektionsschutzgesetz vorgesehen und
sie sind auch bereits heute verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen von der fdp
in der praxis gelebt und zwar durch ein
allseits bekanntes gesetz dem sie mitte
november
ich will über die gründe nicht
spekulieren nicht zustimmen wollten dem
dritten bevölkerungsschutz gesetz jetzt
lese ich in ihrer begründung
zitat der deutsche bundestag der als
gesetzgeber auch die möglichkeit hätte
das bundesrecht zu ändern
und selbst hier durch die maßnahme der
pandemie bekämpfung zu vereinheitlichen
zitat ende also wenn das so ist dann
nutzen sie doch diese möglichkeit denn
der parlamentarismus wurde doch dadurch
gestärkt wie sie sagen wenn sie die
fehler die die koalition macht die
ministerpräsidenten machen wenn sie
diese fehler hier konkret benennen
würden und wenn sie dann sagen würden
das holen wir zurück dem stimmen wir zu
und das beschließen wir anders aber
warum machen sie das denn hier nicht
warum machen sie das denn hier nicht sie
haben die möglichkeit und stattdessen
konzentrieren sie sich nur auf
verfahrensfragen verfahrensfragen sind
richtig aber diese verfahrensfragen
dürfen doch nicht dazu führen dass in
der bevölkerung der eindruck entstehen
muss als wäre eine totale
uneinheitlichkeit da und als gäbe es
keinen diskurs der vernünftig ist und
natürlich ich bin sehr dafür dass wir
die parlamentsrechte stärken
ich bin sehr dafür dass wir in dieser
woche ich glaube 435 minuten im
parlament hierüber mit quid
zusammenhängende sachverhalte
diskutieren
ich bin sehr dafür dass ihr das stärker
nach außen tragen aber ich kann doch
wenn ich vier 135 minuten parlaments
zeit für die kurbel debatten verwendet
nicht sagen
es ist schlecht wenn dann auch mal die
bundeskanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten in dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz weil was
wir brauchen ist natürlich kohärenz im
vorgehen und das was wir liefern heute
das ist leider gottes leider gottes zu
einem großen teil nicht das bemühen um
kohärenz sondern ist zu einem großen
teil der eindruck als ob die
zerstrittenheit und die profilierung der
einzelnen oppositionspartei jeweils für
sich im vordergrund stehen gerüste herr
kollege gestanden sie eine zwischenfrage
der kollegin würden sie mir zustimmen
dass es nicht eine parlamentsvorbehalt
entspricht wenn man mal im parlament
darüber diskutiert und das ist ein
unterschied ist zwischen einem
parlamentsvorbehalt und einem
diskussionsforum halt nach dem motto
schön dass wir mal darüber gesprochen
haben parlamentsvorbehalt heißt dass man
vor dem entscheidungen
[Applaus]
darüber diskutiert und dann entscheidet
verehrte liebe kollegin aschenberg
dugnus natürlich ist es ein unterschied
ob sie über einen antrag diskutieren ob
sie ein gesetz verabschieden ob sie eine
verordnung in den mittelpunkt der
diskussion stellen
aber die frage wie wir mit diesen themen
umgehen liegt doch bei ihnen bei ihnen
bei ihnen bei uns und bei den übrigen
und deswegen ist doch diese frage wie
wir uns dazu verhalten eine die von
unseren entscheidungen hier im parlament
abhängig ist und jetzt verstehe ich dass
sie sagen dass bevölkerungsschutz gesetz
das uns diesen gesamten raum gibt ist
weil die fdp ihm widersprochen hat für
uns nicht der maßstab aber es ist doch
hier im parlament beschlossen worden wir
haben es doch hier im parlament mit der
nötigen mehrheit ausgestattet und jetzt
können sie doch auch jeden paragrafen
dieses bevölkerungsschutz gesetzes
nehmen und sagen den hätten wir gerne
geändert
oder sie können jeder regelung die der
bundesminister für gesundheit trifft
oder den die bundeskanzlerin trifft oder
die sonst jemand griff als übergriffig
bezeichnen und können dann sagen das
muss zurückgenommen haben und sich
können sich dabei auf das
infektionsschutzgesetz und auf das
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz stützen
aber warum tun sie es denn nicht sie
tragen doch dort wo sie die regierungen
mittragen in aller regel dazu bei dass
diese beschlüsse tatsächlich auch
umgesetzt wird ja es regt mich auch auf
das nach jeder dieser konferenzen wo
einheitlichkeit verkündet wird
anschließend jeder teilnehmer dann
irgend eine facette sucht nur ein
bisschen abweicht das recht mich auch
auf aber wenn sie sagen
wir wollen das nicht wir wollen diesen
spielraum nicht dann könnten sie doch
auch konkret sagen also das was jetzt
abweicht in nordrhein westfalen das was
ab reicht in abweicht in schleswig
holstein
das nehmen wir weg oder das was in baden
württemberg abweicht oder das was in
hessen abweicht das soll unterbunden
werden aber darüber müssten wir dann
hier diskutieren und dann müssten sie es
sagen sie machen aber nur
verfahrensdebatten und das finde ich
etwas inhalts arm an bürger ein bürger
aus ilsfeld in baden württemberg karl
kühner den ich überhaupt nicht kenne hat
mich nach der letzten sitzungswoche
allergisch angeschrieben und darum
gebeten hier seinen basis bürger
gedanken vorzutragen es ist nicht meine
aber ich finde es interessant zitat
dadurch dass in den jetzigen
krisenzeiten die theater geschlossen
sind schaue ich mir gerne bundes und
landtag debattiert kostenlos theater
geboten
es ist zwar traurig dass ich so etwas
schreiben muss aber das niveau hat doch
deutlich nachgelassen
zitat ende herr kollege hänge ich gibt
nur eine zwischenfrage von der kollegen
straetmanns die linien da muss ich das
nachher weiter auf dem wagen
vielen dank dass sie die zwischenfrage
zu lassen herr kollege ich glaube eins
ist doch klar geworden aus dem antrag
der fdp und aus unserem antrag für ein
pandemie gesetz und aus bemühungen der
grünen dass wir insgesamt eine
verstärkte debatte nicht nur im
parlament einfordern und verlangen
sondern dass wir auch eine bessere
information haben wollen und wenn sie
sich dauerhaft hier verweigern
dann sollen sie auch dafür dass die
akzeptanz aller maßnahmen zur bekämpfung
der krise in der bevölkerung immer mehr
verloren geht ich würde ihnen empfehlen
sich doch mal den ansichten der
opposition anzunähern weil eine solche
krise kriegen wir nur gemeinsam in einem
demokratischen diskussions und
entscheidungsprozesse gelöst beispiel
wir werden ja jetzt in diesen tagen noch
eine debatte haben um die frage wie wir
mit den schnelltests umgehen wollen also
den antigen tests die nicht von
professionellen durchgeführt werden
müssen durch die test abnahme sondern
die von den bürgern selbst durchgeführt
werden können als google teste oder als
spuckt este diese debatte beispielsweise
findet sich in einem antrag wieder den
die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
eingebracht hat frau hilde mattheis weiß
dass wir beide in der vorigen woche am
rande des ausschusses für gesundheit
diese frage diskutiert haben wir haben
sie auch mit dem bundesminister für
gesundheit diskutiert und wir haben
wunder jetzt einen referentenentwurf für
eine rechtsverordnung vorliegen die
genau diesen punkt auf greift also ich
finde es ich finde es auch falsch die
dinge so darzustellen als ob ihre themen
nicht wahrgenommen würden und nicht
diskutiert würden das gegenteil ist der
fall
und die berichtspflicht der
bundesregierung ist ja nicht nur
gesetzestext sondern sie ist auch
gelebte praxis
wir haben sie im november in § 5
infektionsschutzgesetzes noch einmal
explizit bekräftigt und die mitglieder
des gesundheitsausschusses und wir hier
im parlament wissen dass wir inzwischen
auch vor jeder bund länder konferenz
digitale sondersitzung des ausschusses
mit dem bundesministerium für gesundheit
machen vielleicht sollten sie sich in
ihren fraktionen genauso mit den
gesundheitspolitikern austauschen wie
wir das in unseren fraktionen machen
vielleicht wäre das auch mal die idee
des informationsflusses und ansonsten
immer auf verlangen und die
bundeskanzlerin steht hier auch in den
fragestunden der bundesregierung rede
und antwort und deswegen ist es legitim
diesen antrag einzubringen
deswegen ist es auch richtig dass wir
den antrag dann anschließend diskutieren
in der ausschussberatung oder werden
dann auch noch mal auf herz und nieren
prüfen
aber sie täten ihren eigenen anliegen
einen größeren gefallen wenn sie sagen
würden was sie geändert haben wollen wo
sie andere schwerpunkte setzen wollen
anstatt sich nur auf verfahrensfragen zu
konzentrieren bedanke mich für die
aufmerksamkeit
rudolf henke für die cdu/csu eine
interessante debatte es geht um nicht
mehr und nicht weniger als die frage
stärkung des parlaments in epidemischen
lagen dass der oberste gesetzgeber quasi
mitbestimmen kann wie die
bundesregierung in diesen verhandlungen
im kanzleramt zu bestimmen hat das ist
exekutives handeln wird auf der anderen
seite häufig gesagt und schränkt dann
die verhandlungsführung zb der
bundeskanzlerin doch massivst 1
der nächste redner jetzt hier von der ft
und fdp tobias matthias peterka die
gewaltenteilung retten
das habe ich zumindest kurz gedacht als
ich gestern den gesetzentwurf gesehen
habe aber sind wir doch mal ehrlich
das wäre so als würde man einen
hausbrand mit einer flasche selters
löschen wollen ein haus und bei dem die
fdp selber fleißig mit gezündet hat die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite mitbeschlossen
der kritisierte und länder klüngel lange
toleriert und noch selber ins
weltuntergangs horn mit gestoßen und ja
ja ein bisschen wurde von der fdp immer
traurig geschaut und dann auch als show
die aufhebung der lage beantragt im
november aber dann wurde sich wieder nur
enthalten
bravo aber das reicht nicht liebe fdp
bei der feier cupid 19 welle haben
unsere entscheidungsträger auf allen
ebenen krachend versagt staatsversagen
nicht weniger hört in den
geschichtsbüchern stehen nicht weniger
wird in jura und politik vorlesungen
einzug halten als klassisches beispiel
einer unverhältnismäßigen panischen und
arroganten reaktion auf neue sachlage
und ja das virus ist neu dass wir aus
ist nicht ungefährlich für geschwächte
menschen aber wenn unsere gewählten
entscheidungsträger in bund und land
derart kopflos nur in maximal maßnahmen
rein rennen dann ist das feige und wenn
sie sich dafür ein verfassungs fremdes
direktorium gründen das grundrechte
wirtschaft und parlamenten für
zweitrangig erklärt dann ist das
gefährlich das direktorium das
direktorium bund länder runde ist
verfassungswidrig es geht de facto weit
über die notstandsgesetzgebung der 1960
er jahre hinaus und wenn sie mir jetzt
kommen es sind nur empfehlungen die
kommunen die länder können ja noch frei
entscheiden
dann will ich ihnen mal eins sagen in
dieser bund länder runde herrscht schon
lang die unkommentiert jetzt ist man so
weit gegangen jetzt muss im nachhinein
alles gerechtfertigt werden von merkel
über sparen bis zu seiner und jeden
beliebigen landrat vorwärts immer
rückwärts nimmer ein ganz ungesunder 3
der aus der panischen angst vor dem
wähler gespeist wird und das und das
liebe fdp wird jetzt alles dadurch
geheilt dass ein inter mehrheit sowieso
von regierungen der ak wie beeinflusst
der bundestag so hopplahopp coroner
maßnahmen absegnen soll
zur not also wohl in der regel sowieso
im nachhinein das ist doch ein
feigenblatt das direktorium wird weiter
die regieren dann eben über diese
zusätzliche bande als ob die
regierungsfraktionen ernsthaft
alternativen andenken würden als ob die
grünen ernsthaft zu echten
güterabwägungen in der lage wären der
einsatz von glaubwürdigkeit ist schon
derart massenhaft auf den poker tisch
gelegt dass es kein zurück mehr gibt
recht behalten oder abwahl sieg oder
untergang das war noch immer die losung
in jedem bunker prost mahlzeit
[Applaus]
für die spd bekommt jetzt das ford
sabine dittmer die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der sozialdemokraten es geht
um die frage wie das parlament stärker
in die beratungen eingebunden werden
kann die ist ja regelmäßig im kanzleramt
gibt zwischen ministerpräsidenten und
bundeskanzlerin
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der fdp in den vergangenen
monaten haben sie mit einigen durchaus
guten parlamentarischen initiativen
wichtige debatten in der korona krise
bewegt und angeregt
der vorliegende gesetzentwurf den sie
mit stärkung des parlaments
überschreiben und dem zudem sie hier
auch wieder sehr wasserreich mit
höchsten appellen an die
parlamentarische demokratie vorgetragen
haben der gehört definitiv nicht dazu
ihr politisches der politisches kalkül
ist leicht zu durchschauen den dort wo
sie auf landesebene mitregieren und in
der landesregierung
entscheidungsspielraum wir brauchen
haben parlamentsrechte für sie nämlich
keinerlei priorität und blicken wir doch
mal nach nordrhein-westfalen gesetz zur
parlamentarischen absicherung der
rechtssetzung in der comic 19 pandemie
steht über den entwurf sie haben es
zitiert in ihrem entwurf findet sich
aber nichts was auf eine stärkere
parlamentsbeteiligung hinweisen lässt
sie wollen kein zustimmungsvorbehalt für
das parlament bei verordnungen die in
grundrechte eingreifen sie wollen kein
einspruchsrecht des parlaments gegen
alle anderen verordnungen
sie wollen keine verbindliche abstimmung
von maßnahmen zwischen dem parlament um
der landesregierung für die
unterrichtung des parlaments genügt
ein schriftlicher bericht einmal im
monat sofern die regierungsinterne
willensbildung abgeschlossen ist
all das all das wofür sie hier auf
bundesebene so vehement streiten ist der
fdp auf landesebene
dort wo nach dem infektionsschutzgesetz
wesentliche entscheidungen mit
grundrechts relevanz für bürgerinnen und
bürgerinnen zur eindämmung der pandemie
beschlossen werden nicht die baby wert
das ist ihr verständnis von
parlamentsbeteiligung
vielleicht gleich schicken sie ihre
nordrhein-westfälischen kolleginnen und
kollegen beispielsweise mal das berliner
polit neuesten
parlamentsbeteiligungsgesetz dort finden
sie wertvolle anregungen auf bundesebene
rufen sie gleichzeitig immer wieder nach
mehr parlamentsbeteiligung obwohl dieses
parlament vielfältige
beteiligungsmöglichkeiten hatte und auch
nutzt
wir haben die bundesregierung gesetzlich
verpflichtet neben den regierungs
befragungen regelmäßig mündlich zu
gerichten darüber hinaus geraten wir in
fast jeder debatte zeitbedingt der dampf
der pandemie hier wöchentlich die
situationen das geschehen gestern erste
aktuelle stunde beantragt durch die
koalitionsfraktionen weil die linke die
von ihr geplante abgesagt hat uns ist es
wichtig das thema hier zu debattieren
der bundestag wird im februar die
sitzungswoche nach vorne ziehen um im
vorfeld der bund-länder-arbeitsgruppe
die aktuelle situation zu behörden in
sonder ausschusssitzungen vor und nach
dem bund länder treffen beraten wir die
situation weil es ihnen von der
fdp-präsident politisch profitabel
erscheint fordern sie trotzdem plakativ
mehr parlamentarische rechte ein an
anderer stelle
dort wo tatsächlich entscheidungen zu
treffen sind aber leider nicht ihr
gesetzentwurf ist ein feigenblatt und
mehr auch nicht
die kolleginnen und kollegen mit dem
vorliegenden gesetzentwurf soll die
bundesregierung verpflichtet werden eine
zustimmung des deutschen bundestages
einzuholen wenn sie beabsichtigt im
rahmen der bund länder koordination
bundeseinheitliche maßnahmen
herbeizuführen
die scheibe es für den ureigenste
aufgabe der bundesregierung in der band
die begrenzung auf eine möglichst
weitgehend einheitlich drei der länder
entscheidungen abhängig vom jeweiligen
infektionsgeschehen hinzuwirken
wir wissen doch wir wissen doch nach
einem jahr voller in deutschland dass
die eindämmung eines solchen
flächendeckenden infektionsgeschehen es
nur durch möglichst einheitliches und
vergleichbares handeln gelingt aber am
ende aber am ende sind es die
bundesländer die nach geltenden
infektionsschutzgesetz konkrete
regelungen treffen sowie absprachen um
verständigungen verbindlich umsetzen
sie tun dies in eigener verantwortung
und abwägung und die konkrete
beteiligung der parlamente an diesen
entscheidungen in vielen bundesländern
zeigt aber auch dass empfehlungen
verabredungen der bund länder
konferenzen bei weitem nicht nur blind
links nachvollzogen werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
die frage der parlamentsbeteiligung auf
bundesebene immer wieder breit
diskutiert um zuletzt im november im
vergangenen jahr im dritten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz auch noch
ergänzende regelungen getroffen
ich denke transparenz information und
aufklärung über entscheidungsprozesse
ist uns allen ein wichtiges anliegen und
deshalb beraten wir ja auch
fraktionsübergreifend und ich weiß wir
sind hier auch mit den
oppositionsfraktionen im gespräch in
welcher form wird zum beispiel ich nenne
das jetzt mal arbeitstitel in der
disziplin ära pandemie ausschuss in dem
wir so etwas einsetzen können um direkt
wären arbeitsstrukturen sinnvoll weiter
zu ergänzen
kolleginnen und
legen die pandemie die werden wir nur
gemeinsam bekämpfen
deshalb lassen sie uns zusammen bleiben
bleiben sie gesund und passen sie weiter
auf sich und ihre nächsten auf ich danke
für die aufmerksamkeit
sabine dittmar hier diesen chats
politische sprecherin der spd hat ja
einmal die fdp angegriffen und die
etablierung fordert dass das parlament
künftig im vorfeld beteiligt wird in
gesetzesform fordern sie dass bei den
rednerinnen und redner cdu csu und der
spd warum sie im pandemie zeiten hier
überhaupt noch erscheinen wenn sie
finden die bundesregierung macht das
alles alleine und gut mit den
ministerpräsidenten da können sie
einfach zu hause bleibt kann doch nicht
allen ernstes wie engagiert die
kolleginnen und kollegen heute fest die
fdp hat zum zweiten mal in dieser
wahlperiode in vier jahren einen
brauchbaren antrag hier vorgelegt den
werden wir sehr wohlwollend begleiten
das ist finde ich sehr wichtig und
notwendig darüber zu sprechen worum geht
es in dieser frage alle kennen die
berühmten merkel und ministerpräsidenten
runden wo also das ganze land wartet
gebannt vom bildschirm was denn jetzt
neues verkündet wird das grundproblem
dabei ist doch folgendes erstens ist
diese runde nirgendwo in der verfassung
überhaupt vorgesehen daran müsste man
mal kurz erinnern
zweitens tag diese hunde ja
ausschließlich nicht öffentlich und zum
dritten will ich dazu sagen sie wird
vorbereitet von beratern und
wissenschaftlern die völlig
intransparent zusammengesetzt sind und
wo man sich fragt ob das eigentlich
nicht auch ein wenig einseitig ist all
das könnten wir mit diesem gesetz der
fdp ändert
und ich will und ich will und ich will
noch mal eins wirklich ganz deutlich
sagen es ist eine grundsatzfrage ist
unsinnig eine demokratische
grundsatzfrage nämlich die wenn
grundrechte eingeschränkt werden dann
darf das doch das sagt doch auch die
geschichte eigentlich nicht eigentlich
niemals durch verordnung und regierung
geschehen
das muss hier diskutiert und hier
entschieden oder abgelehnt werden
das war eine grundsatz verständigt
jemand sich dem entziehen kann und die
idee der grundrechte ist doch gerade die
dass die grundrechte natürlich und
besonders in krisenzeiten gelten und
geschützt werden müssen und deswegen
kann man damit nicht so latz umgehen wie
dass dieses letzte ja hier geschehen ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
versammlungsfreiheit bewegungsfreiheit
die religionsfreiheit diese so
wertvollen rechte können nicht einfach
per verordnung so aufgehoben werden und
deswegen ganz konkret müssten wir
folgendes tun
sie sagen ja dass hier ständig über
diese ganzen fragen diskutiert werde ich
will mal eins sagen ohne den druck
zumindest eines teils der opposition
kollege gross und römer ohne den druck
in der öffentlichkeit und durch die
medien würde die bundeskanzlerin hier
gar nicht mehr ein schweben und ihre
politik darstellen um das mal klar zu
sagen es kommt doch nicht von ihnen
erzählen doch nicht zu sein hier
und deswegen und deswegen die grünen
nicht weißen werden gleich der
bundesregierung zur seite springen das
ist ja auch klar das können sie dann ja
auch gleich machen ich möchte aber noch
einmal deutlich sagen
der sinn der sinn ist doch wenn wir
diese ministerpräsidenten runden haben
das nicht danach wenn denn lediger weise
überhaupt sondern vorher die
bundeskanzlerin hier vortrag was sie
dort gedenkt zu tun und vorzuschlagen
das ist doch logisch so zu verfahren und
nicht dann wenn es gewesen ist und dann
müssen wir darüber entscheiden ob das
was dort vorgeschlagen ist dass
zumindest die bundeseinheitlichen
regelungen angeht ob der bundestag jeder
einzelne abgeordnete dem zustimmen kann
oder nicht das ist doch ganz
übersichtlich so zu verfahren und im
übrigen
ist doch auch für die bundesregierung
die im moment wirklich also das
impfstoff desaster und vieles andere
mehr
es könnte doch auch eine gewisse hilfe
und unterstützung für sie sein wenn sie
zunächst einmal die gehören könnten was
hier verschiedene fraktionen
verschiedene abgeordnete eigentlich
machen
ich glaube das könnte ihnen hilfreich
sein letzter punkt entscheidend ist doch
dass wir das hier machen dass wir die
akzeptanz die sind in der bevölkerung
dass wir versuchen dadurch dass es hier
transparent und breit diskutieren
diese akzeptanz wieder zu erhöhen und
die leute mit zu machen dass sie sehen
hier werden sorgen und ängste
wahrgenommen hier werden vor allem auch
die schwächsten und ärmsten thematisiert
die ansonsten keinen zugang zur
öffentlichkeit haben das könnte die
akzeptanz erhöhen
und deswegen werden wir ausgesprochen
wohlwollend konstruktiv den heute
vorgelegten vorschlag der fdp
unterstützen sollten wir auch tun so
deutet sich interessanter
schulterschluss an zwischen fdp und
linken das war aber in dieser frage in
den letzten monaten immer schon zu hören
beide fraktionen beharren darauf dass
das parlament mehr zu beteiligen ist
manuela rottmann jetzt für die damen und
herren wenn marco buschmann hier willy
brandt an berufen wenn er einen
gesetzentwurf einbringt dann erwarte ich
großes die fdp kreiste und sie gebar
eine ameise und die linkspartei ist
drauf reingefallen
wen oder was schon das steht nicht im
gesetz entworfen
wem oder wozu soll der bundestag
eigentlich zustimmen der absicht der
bundesregierung an bund länder
koordinierung herbeizuführen termin
tagesordnung kaffeepausen oder den
vorschlägen der bundesregierung für die
koordinierung sie beantworten das nicht
in ihrem gesetzentwurf
wir grüne sind definitiv der auffassung
dass die information durch die
bundesregierung deutlich verbessert
werden kann haben das mehrfach beantragt
wir kämpfen seit monaten für die
einsetzung eines pandemie rats und ich
hoffe dass das was ich gerade von sabine
bittner gehört habt nicht nur ein
versprechen war aus dem widder nix wird
aber die fdp in ihrem antrag euro die
fdp bescheidet sich mit der transparenz
darüber mit welchen vorschlägen ich
zitiere mit welchen vorschlägen die
bundesregierung in die bund- länder-
koordination hineingegangen ist und wie
sich dies im ergebnis widerspiegelt das
ist ja echt der hammer was zur hölle
soll das sie stärken doch damit nicht im
bundestag sie machen aus ihm ein
schlaumeier am spielfeldrand der die
strichliste über gewonnene zweikämpfe in
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz führen
darf diese rolle markt ihnen liegen
airbus man uns liegt sie nicht was und
wer was in der unter den voraussetzungen
der pandemie darf ist nicht ausreichend
klar geregelt da widersprechen henke und
ich widerspreche auf frau dittmer der
bürger kann es nicht vorher sind und mit
dem 28a der ein schritt in die richtige
richtung ist kommen wir nicht durch die
nächsten monate davon bin ich überzeugt
aber wir müssen die
verordnungsermächtigung im
infektionsschutzgesetz anpacken die
müssen genauer gefasst werden und das
mit der nötigen flexibilität zu machen
das ist wirklich schwierig die
wesentlichen entscheidungen müssen vom
bundestag selbst getroffen werden aber
mit der zustimmung zur tagesordnung der
ministerkonferenz können sie das doch
nicht ersetzen also nichts von dem was
die wesentlichkeit theorie verlangt
erfüllt der antrag der fdp der
gesetzentwurf
und jetzt einmal zum schluss also werk
zeit wieder viele männer präsentieren
sich in den letzten tagen als experten
für kuschel opposition und wissen immer
ganz genau welche kuschel opposition ist
ich will immer eines sagen ich habe
viele viel mit kollegen der koalition
geredet warum
diese koalition in manchen punkten nicht
so stur weigert die
verordnungsermächtigung zu
konkretisieren und ich will hier machen
ähnlich
das hat einen namen das ist die
rennsport
wir haben das problem nicht mit der
justiz ministerin und wenn ich richtig
informiert bin ist ihr
fraktionsvorsitzender ganz eng mit ihren
sparen und ich würde mal sagen diesen
namen hier nicht zu nennen
das ist die höchste form von kusel
opposition herzlichen glückwunsch
[Applaus]
das kreiste der berg und es war eine
ameise
das nehmen wir mal so mit der nächste
redner jetzt carsten müller für die cdu
csu hat er jetzt das wort es geht nach
wie vor um den gesetzentwurf der fdp zu
stärkung des parlaments in epidemischen
lagen
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren lassen sie mich das
fazit meiner rede gleich vorweg nehmen
die fdp hätte beim credo ihrer die
teddys der momentanen legislaturperiode
eigentlich bleiben sollen besser kein
entwurf als ein grottenschlechter
gesetzesentwurf und dann wäre uns vieles
erspart geblieben
schon in ihrer grundannahme der ihrem
vorspann zu entnehmen laufen sie in die
höhe richtet ihre eine öffentliche
diskussion wie in einem
gesetzgebungsverfahren in dem alle
positionen zu wort kommen und bedenken
und verbesserungsvorschläge vorgebracht
werden können findet nicht statt
in der unmittelbar vor laufenden debatte
berühmte sich ihr fraktionsvorsitzender
dass sie in vielen debatten irrsinnig
gute vorschläge eingebracht hätten da
müssen sie sich mal entscheiden gab es
die debatten gab sie nicht sie schreiben
unsinn und diese irre leitung erklärt
auch ihren abenteuerlichen antrag
meine damen und herren ich will ihnen
vor beispiel gegeben
435 minuten sind genannt worden in
dieser von acht aktuelle stunden 285
anträge mehr als 500 kleine anfragen
mehr als 1500 schriftliche und 300
mündliche fragen an die bundesregierung
sechs regierung regierungserklärungen 12
regierungs befragen
das protokoll des bundestages weiß das
wort krone im letzten jahr über 5.400
mal aus und noch viel wichtiger
52 gesetzgebungsverfahren davon die
meisten die meisten von der koalition
sie sind auch die besten und einige
wenige von der opposition
die haben keine mehrheit gefunden 52
gesetzgebungsvorhaben meine damen und
herren in unterschiedliche ausschüssen
und experten anhörung wurde das thema
diskutiert und meine damen und herren
was mich besonders erschreckt ihre
ausführung in ihrem vorgelegten
gesetzesentwurf der passt übrigens auf
so eine din a6 seite in ausreichend
großer schrift sind nicht nur
irreführend sondern unredlich sie sind
deswegen unredlich weil sie ein bewusst
falsches bild zeichnen und das kennt man
eigentlich nur von ihren sitznachbarn
zur echten sie stehen sich dort in eine
reihe richtig ist in diesem haus ist
richtig ist wie sie kommen ab und zu mal
mit rechts und links durcheinander
richtig ist allerdings dass in diesem
haus kein thema wie das gewohnt thema im
vergangenen jahr und wahrscheinlich in
der gesamten geschichte des bundestages
so intensiv diskutiert worden ist um
meine damen und ich finds auch unredlich
dass sie die abstimmung zwischen bund
und den ländern kritisieren und
diskreditieren wollen meine damen und
herren auf basis der jeweils von den
parlamenten im bund und in den ländern
beschlossenen gesetzlichen rahmen sind
genau dort wo die exekutive beauftragt
ist zu handeln die maßnahmen eingeleitet
und verabschiedet worden jede der
einzelnen entscheidungen ist
parlamentarisch kontrolliert und
legitimiert wer etwas anderes behauptet
und das machen sie nicht den axt an
unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung damen und herren sie
schreiben im übrigen sie schreiben im
übrigen das die bundesregierung wenn sie
bundeseinheitlichen beschlüsse ja ich
frage sie denn was denn sonst
als bundeseinheitliche beschlüsse von
der bundesregierung
angeregt das zeigt schon mal dass sie
sich auch in ihren eigenen texten
vollkommen verändert haben meine damen
und herren ein parlament muss nicht
jeder einzelmaßnahme der exekutive einer
regierung zu stimmen
die kollegen der spd hat sich dieser
weise gesagt in den landesregierungen in
denen die fdp beteiligen
überschaubare anzahl zugegebenermaßen
passiert das warum nicht sie werden
ihren eigenen ansprüchen überhaupt nicht
gerecht und meine damen und herren wir
haben das sorgfältig gelesen ging
relativ schnell also bei intensiven
befassung mit ihrem gesetzentwurf
braucht man etwa 15 sekunden das
vollständig durch zu den sie werden
ihren eigenen ansprüchen nicht gerecht
wir werden den ansprüchen gerecht
ein gutes beispiel ist das verfahren zum
dritten gesetz zum schutz der
bevölkerung bei einer epidemischen lage
von nationaler tragweite nur am rand das
ist einmal kurz erbringt erwähnt wurden
sie wollten bereits feststehen dass es
diese lassen dass es diese pandemische
lage nicht mehr gibt das zeigt also sie
sind sozusagen starts organisatorisch
und inhaltlich komplette irrläufer
erschreckend meine damen und herren und
das wundert mich bei ihnen herr dr
buschmann gegen ist offensichtlich das
thema der gewaltenteilung angekommen
vollkommen ab angekommen ich konsumiere
sie zeigen hier häufig eine ganz gute
präzision in ihren ausflug nichts mehr
da nichts mehr dabei bei ihm das
parlament kontrolliert die regierung es
ersetzt nicht die regierung
und das ist ihrem antrag wohl doch eines
in der tiefe schmerz vor etwas über drei
jahren eine na ja ähnlich irrsinnige
entscheidung getroffen zu haben wie sie
mit diesem antrag hier um diesen
gesetzentwurf heute wieder zur
abstimmung stehen meine damen und herren
ich will das thema denken möglichkeit
der gerichtlichen überprüfung gar nicht
noch ansprechen aber was ich
bemerkenswert finde sie erfreuen sich
der unterstützung der linkspartei
glückwunsch dazu sie sind endgültig in
der politischen tandy crash wieder
angekommen
das thema war das für die cdu csu
er hat hier auch nochmal das problem des
exekutiven handelns der bundesregierung
angesprochen das spielt auch häufig eine
rolle in untersuchungsausschüssen zum
beispiel der nächste redner jetzt stefan
bayhunter für die afc frau präsidentin
meine damen und herren alles wie immer
von hassel manche mit der hier in
angriffsposition aber ich kann sie
berühren fesselmann ich lobe zunächst
mal die rede von frau rottmann tolle
rede
inhaltlich haben sie mir einiges weg
genommen deshalb kann ich mich umso
kürzer fassen
gute rede auch von herrn müller ich weiß
nicht ob sie mitbekommen haben das ja
muss man dazwischen gerufen hat sie
während ein hexer aber so sind hat die
reden die wahl der fdp dann nicht so
genehm sind mein name und herren wir
reden über einen fdp-antrag titel gesetz
zur stärkung des parlaments in
epidemischen lagen von nationaler
tragweite er denkt man sich bei dem
titel jetzt jetzt richtig
liberaldemokratische und parlament
stärken das denkt man aber nur kurz so
kurz nämlich bis man ihren gesetzentwurf
durchgesehen hat fünf blätter davon zwei
nur halb beschrieben eine seite frost
köln eine halbe seite nahmen bleiben
netto zweieinhalb seiten die
gesetzesänderung umfasst gerade mal fünf
zeilen und zwei sitze die irgendwo im
infektionsschutz anzuhängen sind meiner
mutter und die beiden sätze sind auch
noch inhaltlich von der auch die geklaut
ich verweise beispielhaft auf unseren
antrag tiefe grundrechtseingriffe
bedürfen der parlamentarischen kontrolle
vom ersten sieben 2020 der vor über
sieben monaten von der afg hier
eingebracht wurde und den sie gemeinsam
von allen block mit allen blockparteien
abgelehnt haben
es kreist der bergmann und gebar nicht
einmal ein mäuschen sie habe die ameise
genannt auch die ist noch übertrieben
merken sie was ihr von der afg bringen
gute gesetze gute ideen gute anträge ein
sie von den blockparteien läden
geschlossen mit albernen begründung
versuchen ab und bringen sie dann kurze
zeit später wieder ein das ist nicht
gerade die feine englische art aber was
soll's hauptsache die afg politik wird
umgesetzt wir machen politik über
die bande die nur wie ein fdp klassiker
gackern wenn andere ein ei legen und
sich selbst als politisches winter
erweisen das sind sie von der fdp ein
fähnchen im winde und genauso auch hier
bei dieser thema die kleine zeit gaben
sie sich ganz staatstragenden merkel
braucht christian hinten wo es
eigentlich ist wahrscheinlich der
gesetzentwurf wahrscheinlich zum teil
nicht dass er gar nicht auf traute
auftaucht heute christian lindner
jubelte zunächst über klarheit
besonnenheit transparenz die
bundesregierung müsse in dieser
unsicheren lage gestützt werden
diejenigen die jetzt das krisen
management verantwortung trügen müssten
die ungeteilte stunden unterstützung des
parlaments erhalten das war christian
lindner im nachgang zum thüringentag da
war einiges wiedergutzumachen dann
monatelanges schweigen der fdp zu
massiven grundrechtseingriff um zum
einsperren zum drangsalieren der bürger
dafür aber weiterhin bejubeln von merkel
entscheidungen die gesamte blockparteien
schar einschließlich fdp hatte sich
kritiklos und die votum merkel dieses
demokratischen parteien völlig
unwürdigen regierungstreue und
unterwürfige verhalten dauert viele
monate an in denen die afd
seit märz 2020 sich als einzige partei
und fraktion deutschlandweit gegen das
nahezu absolutistisch exekutiv herrschen
in deutschland stimmte die einzige die
für demokratische zustände sorgen wollte
die einzige die die thematik im
bundestag immer wieder hervorbrachte und
die einzige die für grundrechte und
bürgerrechte in diesem land eingetreten
ist wie immer gegen ihren widerstand
lima gegen den widerstand in medien
verbänden und kirchen nun herr kubicki
hat das aufmerksam verfolgt hat
wahrscheinlich dann auch gesagt leute
von fdp macht doch mal irgendwann kam es
jetzt zwar sehr spät oberflächlich
schlecht gemacht aber immerhin zu diesem
gesetzentwurf der aber mein namen und
zahlen auch beweist dass die fdp weder
durchblick noch ahnung hat was wollen
sie mit diesem gesetzentwurf erreichen
sie wollen diese verfassungswidrige
kennen die kreisrunde von frau merkel
diese gebunden bund länder kommission
die sie erwähnen dem gesetzentwurf auch
noch institutionalisieren
also beschlüsse eines gremiums was keine
verfassungsrechtliche grundlage in
deutschland hat was wir von der afg von
anfang an kritisieren wollen sie jetzt
über die hintertür ins
infektionsschutzgesetz einbauen und
diese beschlüsse sozusagen irgendwie
absegnen das ist mit der fdp nicht zu
machen die fdp was ihr vorgelegt haben
ist riesengroß sei murks ich hoffe ich
hoffe gut gedacht ich bin überzeugt ganz
schlecht gemacht vielen dank das mit
applaus hat auch im tank vielen dank das
wort geht einem hilde mattheis von der
spd fraktion
[Applaus]
auch präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine spd fraktion und ich
finde für uns in anspruch und ich glaube
das wird uns niemand ab sagen können
dass wir zutiefst demokratinnen und
demokraten sind und dass wir doch dass
wir das in der vergangenheit bewiesen
haben immer und dass wir in dem was wir
hier tun immer genau diesen
demokratischen anspruch haben und sie
können wir glauben immer dann wenn
jemand willy brandt zitiert geht unser
herz auf
aber nicht immer dann wenn willy brandt
zitiert wird ist auch das was zur
begründung dafür dient richtig und
deshalb sage ich mal hier ich glaube
dass die fdp sich keinen gefallen getan
hat diesen antrag vorzulegen weil wenn
man den text anguckt und es sind
tatsächlich sechs dürre zeilen ist das
nichts anderes als dass die
bundesregierung sich die erlaubnis
abholen soll nämlich mit dem
ministerpräsidenten zu reden
das ist wirklich unter demokratischen
gesichtspunkten eine ziemlich dünne
nummer und dann hätte ich ihn harry
potter auch nicht geraten dass ihr so
hoch zu stilisieren als einen
brauchbaren antrag denn damit haben sie
ihre ganze argumentationskette
eigentlich ad absurdum geführt und ich
glaube dass uns allen klar ist in diesen
schwierigen zeiten braucht ist das
parlament braucht es parlamentarierinnen
und parlamentarier die sich genau mit
diesen dingen auseinandersetzen und die
das auch transparent kommunizieren und
das tun wir
ich weiß nicht wo sie dabei sind wenn
wir in den ausschüssen reden wir sind
dabei von der spd
wir wissen wie viel stunden wir sind
selbstverständlich damit
auseinandersetzen
wir wissen welche harten nachfragen
ersparen da bekommt wir wissen dass wir
in internen gremien in jeder
fraktionssitzung genau rauf und runter
diskutieren und es vergeht keine woche
in der wir nicht mindestens zweimal über
dieses thema debattieren
aber jetzt unter diesen vorzeichen so
einen antrag einzubringen da hätte ich
ihnen dringend von abgeraten und ich
glaube und da habe ich die fdp bisher
immer so erlebt dass ihnen demokratie
auch wichtig ist aber mit diesem punkt
hier glaube ich wollen sie einfach nur
medial wieder mal vorkommt und das ist
schade dazu tragen sie nicht dazu bei
dass wir uns hier wirklich
zielorientiert und sachorientiert mit
diesem thema auseinandersetzen sondern
das ist eine populistische nummer ich
hätte ihnen abgeraten
und wenn wir hier alle miteinander
diskutieren geht es uns doch vor allen
dingen darum dass wir immer wieder auch
reflektieren ob die maßnahmen die
getroffen worden sind maßnahmen zur
jeweiligen situation zu bewältigen sind
und das kann man uns ja hier wirklich
nicht absprechen
und ich glaube auch dass wir mit dem
dritten bevölkerungsschutz gesetz eine
gute grundlage gelegt haben
und da waren doch hier die mehrheit des
parlaments mit einverstanden
ja wir sind immer wieder bereit zu
reflektieren ob das was wir beschlossen
haben jetzt auch noch richtig ist das
werden wir auch in zukunft tun
man muss sich in der politik auch immer
wieder korrigieren dürfen immer wieder
anpassen dürfen
aber das sagt ihr antrag nicht ihr
antrag sagt bitte frau merkel holen sie
unser einverständnis ein dass wir mit
den ministerpräsidenten reden
hallo kann ich da nur sagen hallo dann
hätte ich doch ganz gerne auch mal dass
die ministerpräsidenten die mit frau
merkel reden dann nach hause gehen und
dabei bleiben was sie mit frau merkel
habe ich mein wahlkampf mein wahlkreis
ulm
ich lebe in einem bundesland mit grünem
ministerpräsidenten und ich gucke über
die donau auf einen csu
ministerpräsidenten das ist nicht immer
lustig und wenn dann menschen in ulm
wurden und in neu ulm arbeiten wissen
die nämlich manchmal gar nicht welche
maßnahme für sie eigentlich zutrifft und
das ist ein bisschen schwierig also
vielleicht sollten wir uns was die
kommunikation anbelangt dann einfach mal
ein bisschen konzentrieren auf das was
wirklich gebraucht wird vielen dank
hilde mattheis hat hier der fdp vor oder
mit einen schuh antrag vorzulegen sie
hätte ihnen davon abgeraten susanne
fesche jetzt die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende für die linke hat
sie jetzt das wort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin ist
erfährt die kolleginnen und kollegen die
debatte hat einige erstaunliche
argumente gebracht
beachte ich finde ich allerdings dass
die rede von den grünen bei den
fraktionen die die regierungskoalition
stellt mehr applaus bekommen hat als von
allen anderen ich hoffe sie haben ihre
oppositionsrolle noch nicht völlig
vergessen
wir als linke begrüße die debatte die
die fdp initiiert hat es ist nämlich
eine forderung die wir schon seit
monaten erleben nämlich dass dieses
parlament gestärkt wird in dieser
pandemie und ich persönlich freue mich
ja immer wenn die fdp zu ihren uhr
liberalen themen greift und nicht zum
markt gerade calis muss im ersten block
tagen waren kurzfristige einschneidende
maßnahme notwendig und auch heute
besteht mit blick auf die infektions und
todeszahlen handlungsbedarf
das problem ist nur am ablauf hat sich
nichts geändert nach wie vor entscheidet
die klingel runde zwischen
ministerpräsidenten und kanzlerin und
der vorschlag aus dem kanzleramt der
geistert dann schon tage vorher durch
die presse und am entscheidungstag
erfährt dann deutschland und auch die
gewählten parlamentarierinnen und
parlamentarier dann das ergebnis
irgendwann aus den medien und eines will
ich ihnen auf der regierungsbank sagen
die debatte gehört raus aus dem
kanzleramt gehört hier rein und zwar
bevor die ministerpräsident die
kanzlerin fragen und das ist nicht
passiert
dem wollen wenn du hier wird öffentlich
und transparent über den besten weg
gerungen und alle vorschläge und
bedenken diskutiert
diese debatte sie würde nicht nur die
qualität der maßnahmen sondern auch die
akzeptanz der menschen erhöhen und die
ist dringend notwendig aktuell ist keine
strategie erkennbar
dieses irrlichtern trifft auf eine
erschöpfte gesellschaft auf eltern die
mit homeoffice homeschooling überfordert
sind auch schulkinder die angst haben
zur corinna ponto corinna generation zu
werden und auf menschen die zu hause
bleiben sollen aber nicht überall ist es
zu hause schön die verantwortung für das
infektionsgeschehen wird auf den
einzelnen runtergebrochen das fördert
nicht die solidarität die die kanzlerin
ständig einfordert und ich fühle mich so
ein stück war zurückversetzt in die
kindheit als ich mit meinem vater auf
einer wanderung war und in gefragter
papa wie lang dauert sind eigentlich
noch und er gesagt wir sind gleich da
und ein acht stunden lang gedauert und
ich war frustriert und genau so ist es
jetzt wir hangeln uns von einer
verlängerung zu die zur nächsten ohne
ziel und ohne plan und ja auch wenn die
lage die pandemische lage dynamisch ist
ist das hauruck-verfahren und party
gemacht sie als regierungs die
letztendlich überholt und abschlüssen
bringen noch eines sagen und spätestens
da enden auch wieder etliche
gemeinsamkeiten mit der fdp
wir brauchen andere politische
weichenstellungen das gesundheitswesen
muss endlich der marktlogik entzogen
werden und privatisiert werden unser
sozialstaat muss ausgebaut werden
das sichert nämlich auch die demokratie
vielen dank
am schluss hat susanne verschleudern
darf man in grenzen zur fdp gezogen denn
fdp und linke unterstützten den
gesetzentwurf der liberalen hier
er verlangt dass die bundesregierung im
vorfeld von minister brüderle
mit beschlüssen zu beteiligen hat britta
haßelmann jetzt die erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführerin der
bündnisgrünen meine damen und herren ich
fange mal so an denen ich glaube hier
ist irgendwie ein bisschen was in der
schieflage wenn ich ihren beitrag gehört
habe im ziel einig im weg haben wir
unterschiedliche auffassungen was ist
daran so schlimm was ist daran
eigentlich notwendig ins lächerliche zu
ziehen wenn sie von den linken sich
ihren eigenen pandemie gesetzentwurf
angucken würden und sich darauf beziehen
würden könnten sie diesen gesetzentwurf
hier nicht gut finden
denn er ist in der sache nicht gut und
nur weil das stichwort beteiligung oben
drüber steht ist doch nicht alles gut
jetzt lasst uns doch wirklich man in der
sache diskutieren und lieber marco
buschmann
wir beide arbeiten sehr oft und sehr
viel zusammen deshalb halte ich nichts
von diesen ganzen nummern mit wer ist
jetzt hier die wahre opposition und wer
muss ich morgen überlegen wo der
bleistift ist und wer hier was
vorbereitet hat oder nicht wir beide
wissen nämlich sehr genau wer hier
vorbereitet dinge für das parlament und
für die ausschüsse und für die fragen
was im geschäftsordnungsausschuss an
absicherung für beteiligung des
parlamentes erfolgt im ziel einig
beratung entscheidung und kontrolle
liegen beim parlament
das müssen wir jeden tag aufs neue
durchsetzen und zwar gegenüber der
bundesregierung und der mpk ich habe
schon vor zwei jahren davor gewarnt
welche entwicklung in großen koalition
das institut was es in der verfassung
nicht gibt der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz einnimmt so
weit so schlecht der vorgeschlagene wie
ist aber dennoch schlecht und es ist
legitim und richtig dem parlament
darüber zu diskutieren und darüber zu
bringen was ist denn der beste weg zur
parlamentsbeteiligung und zu deren
absicherung und da sage ich für meine
fraktion genauso wie die kollegin
rottmann es ist nicht der beste weg ein
institut der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz um die es
natürlich gerade nicht geht dass man ein
gremium was gerade nicht in der verpasst
verfassung einen verbindlichen rang hat
etwas regeln kann quasi zu einem gremium
macht das verbindliche entscheidungen
trifft und dass es in ihrem
gesetzentwurf so angelegt meine damen
und herren ich will gar nicht aufwerten
auf gar keinen fall sie ist kein
institut und deshalb trifft sie auch
keine entscheidungen
sie kann empfehlungen abgeben die dann
landesparlamente oder das
bundesparlament oder weil sie mit
mehrheit dem zugestimmt haben die
rechtsverordnung einzelne minister
regeln kann
ich bin ganz klar dafür dass wir die
mehr sparen ein paar kompetenzen
abnehmen und ich freue mich wenn im märz
da alle dabei sind denn dann stehen ganz
viele rechtsverordnung zur verlängerung
an meine damen und herren das sie taten
punkte auch vermisse ich im
gesetzentwurf der fdp den
parlamentsvorbehalt wo ist er denn der
ist nämlich gerade nicht darin wie sie
vorhin gefragt haben
magnus produkte aschenberg wir ist kann
nicht darin vorgesehen das ist nämlich
auch ein problem
und dann ist doch die frage warum suchen
wir nicht noch zwei drei andere wege
das druck gesetzt 84 absatz 2 können wir
ja mal drüber diskutieren die änderung
des 28 infektionsschutzgesetzes bitte wo
waren sie denn da verdanken noch mal der
hat er die begründung und die befristung
durchgesetzte in gesprächen mit der spd
und der cdu csu
und das war verdammt lisa meine damen
und herren wir sollten gemeinsam dank
die wirklichen parlamentsbeteiligung
fragen angehen das
infektionsschutzgesetz § 5 muss geändert
werden 28 muss geändert werden wenn wir
über die stärkung des parlamentes reden
dann da meine damen und herren und da
werden wir vorschläge machen und wir
haben sie auch schon gemacht so liegen
die pala welt vor
vielen dank die tasten amerikanische
geschäftsführung der bündnisgrünen
sie will dem bundesgesundheitsminister
wieder kompetenzen wegnehmen
diese hat er gekriegt durch das gesetz
und die verstellung der epidemischen
lage unter anderem auch von der fdp
unterstützt damals und über das
verordnungs wesen kann der
bundesgesundheitsminister weitreichende
entscheidungen treffen nicht sollte
jetzt hier in der debatte alexander
hoffmann für die cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen gestatten
sie mir drei anmerkungen zum
gesetzentwurf der fdp zunächst einmal
das ist die erste sie erwecken
wiederholt den eindruck dass dieses
parlament im rahmen der pandemie
bekämpfung nicht ausreichend beteiligt
ist das ist nicht richtig
sie verschweigen nämlich auch heute
wieder befindlich das über corona in
diesem parlament exklusiv über kronen
mehr als über 100-mal debattiert worden
ist sie verschweigen dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister der heute bei
der debatte anwesend ist in fast jeder
ausschuss sitzung des
gesundheitsausschusses rede und antwort
steht und zwar allen fraktionen und sie
verschweigen dass zum beispiel das
bundesgesundheitsministerium allein bis
zum 21
diesen jahres 103 anfragen von
abgeordneten dieses hauses bekommen und
beantwortet haben und unter juristen
kollegen buschmann gestatte ich mir auch
mal den lockeren hinweis dass es seit
der pandemie hunderte gerichtliche
anträge im ganzen land gab und nicht
einem einzigen dieser anträge wurde
stattgegeben mit der begründung dass
dieser deutsche bundestag nicht
ausreichend beteiligt gewesen ist
ich möchte zur zweiten anmerkung kommen
sie suggerieren dass der bundestag
zuständig sei für die maßnahmen zur
pandemie bekämpfung der
parteivorsitzende christian lindner ist
ein spezialist darin mit betretener
miene tritt er vor die kameras und ist
besorgt über die parlamentarische
demokratie
fakt ist dass das was er da sagt meine
damen meine herren mit der realität und
der verfassungsrechtlichen
zuständigkeitsverteilung unseres
grundgesetzes überhaupt nichts zu tun
hat
unser staat hören sie mir zu sie haben
von selbst vom gewaltenteilung
gesprochen unser staat wird getragen vom
grundsatz der gewaltenteilung
als wesentliche grundlage und als
wesentliches starts prinzip soll
gewaltenteilung bedeutet drei gewalten
die gesetzgebende gewalt
die ausführende gewalt und die
rechtsprechung de gewalt und das was
jetzt kommt das ist wirklich kein staats
rechtliches hochreck sondern dass es
wikipedia gesetzgebende gewalt sind die
landtage und den bundestag
ausführende gewalt so steht sogar in
wikipedia sind die regierungen und die
verwaltung und die recht sprechende
gewalt das sind die gerichte und dennoch
dennoch erwecken sie immer wieder den
eindruck dass wenn die
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin
zusammen setzen dass da etwas
verfassungsrechtlich furchtbar
unanständiges passiert ich will ihnen
sagen was da passiert da sitzen
diejenigen die zusammen die nach unserer
verfassung zuständig sind für diese
maßnahmen der exekutive
denn die ministerpräsidenten stehen den
exekutivorgan der länder vor
und wenn es um gesetze geht dann ist
dieser bundestag gefragt und dann sind
auch die landtage gefragt
zusammenfassend muss man also sagen dass
das was sie uns heute vorgelegt haben
insoweit hanebüchen ist weil es in
eklatanter art und weise gegen den
grundsatz der gewaltenteilung verstößt
sie fordern eine zustimmung und deswegen
ist das was sie uns heute vorlegen auch
juristisch völlig wert muss und ich
möchte zu meiner dritten anmerkung
kommen
ich sage ihnen von der fdp sie fahren
einen gefährlichen kurs weil sie bewusst
ganz bewusst versuchen sie bei den
menschen falsche eindrücke zu erwecken
und das letztendlich um wählerstimmen ab
zu bekommen und dazu sind sie bereit und
das ist das was ich ihnen persönlich
vorwerfe dazu sind sie bereit eine
spaltung der bevölkerung in kauf zu
nehmen
ihr parteivorsitzender christian linder
blind madrid in diesen tagen vor die
kamera und spricht im rahmen mit dem
problem beim impfen von einem
vorsätzlichen versagen
meine damen meine herren das dach fehler
passieren deswegen niemand
wegdiskutieren hier aber zu behaupten
dass menschen diese fehler wissentlich
und willentlich machen
das ist unanständig
bundestags-vizepräsident kubicki fordert
die menschen anfang november auf wie es
um den lock downlight kind gegen die
maßnahmen der bundesregierung zu klagen
ausnahmsweise mal richtig gegen den
freistaat bayern gab es über 500
verfahren keine zehn haben zum erfolg
geführt und das problem an dieser
aussage ist er suggeriert damit corona
ist nicht so schlimm
zumindest nicht so schlimm die die
freiheitsbeschränkungen wir haben
mittlerweile über 50 tausend tote im
land weil wir in der bevölkerung
tragischerweise tatsächlich manchmal die
stimmungslage haben corona ist nicht so
schlimm und deswegen sage ich ihnen da
wird seiner rolle als
bundestags-vizepräsident mit einer
solchen aussage nicht gerecht und auch
das müssen sie sich an einem solchen tag
wie heute mal sagen lassen
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
tags darauf man hat hier in eine
interessante ausführungen die
gewaltenteilung gebracht ich hatte jetzt
ja auch schon mehrfach erwähnt dass
exekutive handeln der bundeskanzlerin
durch ein gesetz einzuschränken
das dürfte noch unter juristen dann auch
zu diskutieren sein aber die fdp möchte
mehr mitsprache für das hohe haus das
wollen ja viele hier nicht so rednerin
heike behrens von der spd kolleginnen
und kollegen zu wenig zu schnell zu
langsam
so kritisierte gestern der
fraktionsspitze der fdp michael theurer
die arbeit der regierung große töne für
eine partei die im juni 2020 groß
auftrumpfen wollte mit einem antrag der
die epidemische lage für beendet
erklärte wie gut dass sie selbst vor
drei jahren entschieden haben keine
regierungsverantwortung in diesem land
zu übernehmen
in einer debatte zu einem sechs zeilen
an fragt bleibt es nicht aus dass man
sich wiederholen muss in ihrem heute
vorliegenden gesetzentwurf kritisieren
sie dass keine öffentliche debatte über
corona maßnahmen geführt wurde meint sie
das eigentlich wirklich ernst alleine
dieser woche sie haben es gerade gehört
dr buschmann neun einzel debatten zu
diesem wichtigen thema die erringen wir
um den richtigen weg bei der pandemie
bekämpfung die öffentliche diskussion
über die angemessenheit von maßnahmen
zur bewältigung dieser großen
gesundheitskrise findet statt und sie
wird breit geführt es gibt keinen grund
zweifel an der funktionsfähigkeit
unseres staates zu sehen wie es die fdp
heute mit diesem gesetzentwurf und mit
so manch anderen anfragen und anträgen
immer wieder tut denn dies ist mehr als
nur unnötig denn damit zahlen sie immer
auch auf das konto der demokratie vechta
und das ist einfach schrecklich auch
wenn sie das vermutlich so nicht
beabsichtigen
nein es ist keine unverschämtheit
sondern sie müssen auch das verantworten
was sie bewirken
die öffentliche debatte ist ein
wesentliches kernelement unserer
demokratie und sie hatten in den letzten
monaten immer wieder zu wichtigen
kurskorrekturen in dieser schwierigen
gesundheits und wirtschaftskrise geführt
eben weil unsere demokratie funktioniert
weil hierzulande auch die krisen politik
demokratisch kontrolliert und begleitet
wird
und wenn es darum geht die kompetenzen
des parlaments in der pandemie
bekämpfung zu stärken dann haben sie uns
als spd fraktion an ihrer seite
dazu haben wir im herbst bereits
wichtige veränderung vorgenommen und das
infektionsschutzgesetz präzisiert aber
dafür ist es nicht nötig die
demokratische legitimation des
krisenmanagements dieser regierung
anzuzweifeln
völlig zu recht fordert die fdp in ihrem
antrag mehr transparenz ja es braucht
und es gibt diese transparenz und jetzt
lassen sie mich einen etwas anderen
akzent in der debatte setzen denn
permanent wird über vor überlegungen
forderungen zwischenstände und neue
ideen berichtet echte experten und
tausende von hobby virologen und
selbsternannte masken patata wetteifern
über den richtigen weg und den zugang zu
den mikrofonen die omnipräsenz der
pandemie diskussionen und
sondersendungen
medien und netzwerken steigert bei
vielen die orientierungslosigkeit und
vergrößert die ungeduld was wir aber in
dieser phase zurückgehen da aber weiter
hohe infektionszahlen und besorgnis
erregender mutationen wirklich brauchen
ist durchhaltevermögen zutrauen in die
wirksamkeit der getroffenen maßnahmen
und einen langen atem und darum rufe ich
alle demokratinnen und demokraten in
diesem haus und in den anderen
parlamenten unseres landes auf lassen
sie uns gemeinsam und verantwortungsvoll
diesen kraftakt stemmen weiter nach
schaffen wo es nötig ist locker lassen
wo es ohne schaden möglich ist aber vor
allem weiter öffentlich für verständnis
und akzeptanz werben denn es geht noch
immer zuallererst darum gesundheit und
leben zu schützen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
und als letzter redner in der debatte
spricht er wie ein rudel von der cdu csu
fraktion und erwin rüddel ist
vorsitzender des gesundheitsausschusses
des deutschen bundestages
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren
die fdp möchte dass wir vorab etwas
beschließen was nachher als ergebnis als
kompromiss festgelegt wird
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
fdp die sorge um unser grundgesetz und
um die grundrechte unserer bürger in
allen ehren
sie erinnern sich vielleicht daran dass
ich mit den kollegen professor hirte vom
rechtsausschuss anfang november
öffentlich dafür plädiert habe die
rechtlichen möglichkeiten im
infektionsschutzgesetz zu präzisieren
damit die rechtlichen grundlagen
nachgeschärft werden wie das dann auch
ähnlich einige tage später vom bundestag
beschlossen wurde
niemand von uns hat ein interesse daran
rechte des parlaments einzuschränken
oder auszuhebeln ich erinnere in diesem
zusammenhang daran dass der
gesundheitsausschuss auf seine 140
sitzung zusteuert und dass wir in diesem
monat bereits fünf sitzungen des
gesundheitsausschuss hatten an denen
fast immer auch der minister
teilgenommen hat viermal von fünf mal
und ich glaube dass wir nächste woche in
der sitzungsfreien woche die nächste
haben werden
und hier findet ein ausgesprochen
sachkundiger offener transparenter
austausch hat das nur mal zu der
praktischen umsetzung und der
parlamentsbeteiligung
aber werfen wir einen blick auf die
praktischen konsequenzen wenn der
entwurf der fdp gesetz würde die
forderung nach einer entscheidung auf
vorrat seitens des parlaments leuchtet
mir schon deshalb nicht ein weil ja die
konkreten beschlüsse von bund und
ländern überhaupt es aufgrund der
beratung in der kanzler- runde kann
runde zustande gekommen zudem haben wir
es aufgrund der pandemie mit einer
situation zu tun
in der ist jederzeit erforderlich sein
kann gezielt und unverzüglich zu handeln
um die bevölkerung wirksam vor einem
hoch infektiösen virus zu schützen es
liegt nun einmal in der verantwortung
der politik die vitalen und notwendigen
funktionen in der gesellschaft aufrecht
zu erhalten und das ist recht angesichts
möglicher steigerungen von
neuinfektionen todesfällen dem ausbruch
lokaler hotspots oder der drohenden
überlastung von krankenhäusern niemand
bestreitet dass die von der kanzlerin
und den länderchefs praktizierte
bund-länder-kommission in der verfassung
nicht erwähnt wird
sie wird vom gesetzgeber vom grundgesetz
aber auch in keiner weise ausgeschlossen
überdies werden die beschlüsse dieser
runde in der regel gar nicht bundesweit
einheitlich angewandt sondern die
einzelnen länder setzen dass
eigenverantwortlich und häufig durchaus
unterschiedlich um auch gerade mit
beteiligung der fdp
und jemand der als erstes immer gegen
die einem einen sonderweg fordert ist
der stellvertretende ministerpräsident
von rheinland-pfalz der hier in berlin
als generalsekretär ihrer partei tätig
ist der appell der fdp sollte folglich
sich an die länder richten sie sind es
in deren ordinärer kompetenz die
umsetzung der allermeisten beschlüsse
fällt und die länder können durch ihre
parlamente im grund in gesetzesform
gießen was die grunde bei der kanzlerin
beschlossen hat was sie inzwischen auch
teilweise tun meine damen und herren
etwas anderes verhält es sich mit der
ergänzenden forderung der fdp fraktion
für beschlüsse
der bund- länder- koordinierung die
nachträgliche genehmigung durch den
deutschen bundestag einzuholen darüber
werden wir im ausschuss sorgfältig
beraten
ich gebe allerdings zu bedenken was sich
soeben mit dem blick auf die kompetenzen
gesagt haben die konkrete umsetzung der
beschlüsse fällt zumeist in die
zuständigkeit der bundesländer
lassen sie mich abschließen aber
nochmals mit nachdruck unterstreichen
dass die grundrechte unserer bürgerinnen
und bürger nicht in gefahr sind
außergewöhnliche notlagen sind stets
stunden der exekutive aber unser
parlament der deutsche bundestag steht
keineswegs außen vor
basis des staatlichen handelns ist hier
das gesetz zum schutz der bevölkerung
bei einer epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite über das wir im
november diskutiert und entschieden
haben und ich wir werden das dieses
gesetz läuft ende märz aus und das wird
eine neue debatte geben darauf bin ich
gespannt und fest steht das parlament
hat das letzte wort vielen dank
vielen dank ich schließe die debatte